so today we're gonna have sort of a
different kind of class since the last
class today I'm going to talk about
essentially how we bring to bear the set
of issues we've talked about this
semester to a real-world topic and
actually how it plays out in policy in
practice and I'll draw on some my own
experience having applied the kind of
tools we learned in 1401 to the field of
healthcare economics for 25 years and
how that has led me to be able to help
in the development of healthcare policy
in the u.s. and talk about sort of where
healthcare stands healthcare policy
stands at this point so let's do a
little bit of background about
healthcare in the u.s. basically about
healthcare in the u.s. we have to
recognize that the u.s. spends by far
the most money on healthcare of any
developed nation in the world we spend
about 17 and 1/2 percent of our gross
domestic product on healthcare that
amounts to almost ten thousand dollars
per man woman and child every man woman
and child in America that dwarfs the
rest of the world the typical European
nation spends about two-thirds as much
as a percent of GDP on health care
england spends less than half as much on
health care so basically we spend a lot
in health care as a share of our economy
and what do we get for it well um the
evidence here the first fact is clear
the evidence all we get for it's a
little bit mixed so if you look at the
typical thing on the web you know US
health care is terrible our money's
wasted you'll see that on things like
infant mortality we rate like 20th in
the world or life expects they were like
20th in the world so by those metrics we
don't do very well um but in fact those
metrics are misleading because we also
have we have the most unequal health
care system in the world so the right
way to think about is to think about the
haves and the have-nots the haves which
is us and most people in America people
who are well insured in the system
actually get probably the best health
care in the world
okay now that might be disputed by many
people but I think about this like an
economist would think about it we
how would you decide whether people
prefer product a versus product B
whether they buy product a versus
product B every year 1 million people
come to the u.s. to get you for the
healthcare problems no one leaves
no one's going England for surgery no
one's flying from the USA England for
surgery they're coming here if you're in
the system we have the best health care
in the world unfortunate if you're out
of the system we have some of the worst
health care in the world
so white baby born in America today
there's roughly a slightly more than 0.5
percent chance the baby will die in
their first year that's comparable to
that's comparable to northern Europe if
you look at a black baby born in the US
the odds they die in the first year
about twice that which is worse than
Barbados
so the problem in the u.s. is not that
our outcomes are bad the problems
they're very unequal okay that we're
spending all this money we're delivering
good but not exceptional outcomes for
people in the system and bad outcomes
people out the system so Chloe we're not
getting a lot of values not like we
deliver exceptional exceptionally good
outcomes people in the system we're
slightly better just by spending a lot
more and we're worse for many Americans
who are left out of the system so that's
sort of the this set up of where we are
which is really have two fundamental
problems in health care in the u.s. our
spending is too high and our access is
too unequal okay now what's so I want to
focus today's lecture on those two
aspects and think about how can we bring
the kind of lessons we've learned in
this course to thinking about addressing
those problems so let's so I'm going to
focus on the access problem the cost
problem let's start with the access
problem now in America before 2010 we
had about or before 2014 we had about 50
million uninsured Americans 50 million
people who did not have health insurance
in the u.s. we're the only nation in the
world only developed nation in the world
with significant uninsured population
now the fact that 50 million uninsured
is that a problem on its face if I just
said here's a fact 50 million people
America don't have health insurance
based on that fact alone can you tell me
whether there's a problem or not
you should go ahead no why not yeah you
know many more people not don't have
flat-screen TVs and don't own homes why
do we think that we should care if
people don't have something the answer
would be we would only care if what
under what condition when do ya if well
they'd be better off they did have it
now make you better at it because they
could be richer but that's not our
problem given their budget they're not
buying it what what under what condition
is the market not under what type of
conditions with the market not deliver
the best outcome if there's a market
failure so the fact that people aren't
insured doesn't matter except a if
there's a market failure or B for
redistribution purposes remember that's
the two reasons we want the government
involved so if if health insurance
markets were perfectly functioning and
people are uninsured we're roughly
equally distributed income as everyone
else there'd be no cause for worry but
in fact that's not true we've talked in
this class about why marks like health
insurance won't function well which is a
problem of adverse selection okay the
prod there's information phase which
will lead health insurance markets not
to function well and the people
uninsured tend to be much poorer than
the people who are insured it's also
redistribution of concern so the reason
we care about the uninsured are both
because market failures and for
redistribution that they tend to be
lower income what's interesting is the
uninsured don't tend to be the poorest
in society they tend to be the near poor
so here's the way sort of health
insurance coverage works in the US for
the vast majority of Americans 60% of
Americans 600 Americans have what's
called employer sponsored insurance so
like you're most of your parents like me
they get health insurance from their
employer okay the typical upper income
American is health insurance from their
employer typical averaging American does
about 60% of Americans okay
then and I'm going to do this sort of
pre ACA so before 2014 before the big
change that was put in place by
the Affordable Care Act you had about
another maybe six percent that bought
into what we call individual or non
group health insurance that if they went
out on their own and bought insurance
but that's a tiny market compared ESI
and the reason is because of exactly the
adverse selection problem we talked
about think about yourself as an insurer
and you're worried about a versatile
itself an insurer and think about what
your goal is your goals that insurer is
to essentially absorb risk in a way that
allows you to make a profit so what you
want is you want to live off the law of
large numbers you know that with a large
enough group you could be able to
predict what their costs will be and
therefore you can just make a profit on
top so insurers love when MIT comes to
an insurer they're delighted they're
like look you got between MIT and and
Lincoln labs so if you got about ten
thousand employees I with great
certainty can predict what the cost will
be next year for a group of ten thousand
employees and so aizen insurer can know
I can just charge that plus X percent
and I'm golden
but when John Gruber walks in the door
they're like why you coming to me
individual maybe because you know you're
sick maybe because you love skydiving I
don't know but I'm wary of you so I'm
gonna charge you a lot of money to get
health insurance as a result most very
few people bought health and show on
their health insurance on their own and
in particular the reason they didn't is
because insurers would not offer health
insurance to people if they were at all
sick they would do things like having
what we call pre-existing conditions
exclusions these were features of
insurance contracts which said look you
walked in the door John and you want
health insurance but I know in the past
you've had cancer or asthma or knee
surgery I'm gonna say I'm gonna insure
you but not for any expenses that might
arise from recurrence of those past
injuries to cancer in the past and that
comes up in the future because you had
cancer I'm not gonna cover a the couples
of the future because you had knee
surgery I'm not going to cover anything
comes the future because you had ads but
I'm not going to cover it so I'm going
to give you essentially partial
sure there's gonna be a market failure
I'm gonna insure you but only for part
of what you need okay
alternatively they could use
pre-existing condition exclusions they
could use what's called medical
underwriting which was basically saying
okay John come in I'm gonna give an exam
if you look sick I'm gonna deny you
insurance or if you look sick I'm gonna
charge you a hundred times more than
someone else so these were not illegal
or even immoral these were just ways
insurers came up with to try to deal
with the adverse selection problem as a
result this was a market that did not
function very well question about that
no totally legal in every state
virtually every state totally legal and
not immoral I mean this is just their
maximizing their profits so what
companies do and the point is that when
they did this what this meant was if you
didn't have an employer-sponsored
insurance or sure so the governor to
come to next then you were subject to
the fact that if you got sick you might
like it might not be able to get
insurance which is sort of weird and
shirin supposed to cover if you were
sick but in fact if you were sick you
might not be able to get it okay so that
was the fundamental market failure we
had here through adverse selection
now we also thousand ploy response
insurance so that was about two-thirds
of the population okay you also had on
the order of 15 percent of the
population had government sponsored
insurance probably more like twenty
percent twenty percent private is a
government-sponsored insurance the two
big programs here are called Medicare
and Medicaid now if you ever take my
1441 class I will only hold you
responsible easy to program z' okay
Medicare is health insurance for the
elderly
Medicaid is health insurance for the
poor and those are our two big public
insurance programs okay in about twenty
and if you're in those programs are also
set they don't have any of these
features if you're in your covered
forever
okay so about about 20% of people are
there and then finally if you add up the
numbers we had about 15 numbers so quite
add up but you know about 15% of the
population was uninsured 15 percent
uninsured see about two thirds private
about one-fifth public in about
one-sixth uninsured okay and those
individuals who typically were not the
poorest because the poorest people got
medicaid the typical uninsured person is
like a what we call the working poor
someone who's got a job but it's a
crappy jobs that are off for health
insurance but they make enough money
they can't qualify for being in the
low-income program so your family
struggling it like 40 50 thousand
dollars a year high enough income that
they're not qualifying for Medicaid but
not a good enough job they're getting
health insurance that's your typical
uninsured family two thirds of the
uninsured are in families that are
headed by a full-time full-year worker
okay they're not the typically the
unemployed down their luck people they
develop the people who are trying to
play by the rules they say in politics
but simply can't get a job with health
insurance okay so that's your basic
landscape and when we know from that
landscape is that a lot of the access
problems were because of this group and
this group because the people who
couldn't get in this market and as a
result we're often uninsured that was a
lot of what drove the access problems so
that was sort of the first that's aford
that's one of the two big problems that
face our system and for many many years
we know we had that problem and for
about a hundred years about we've tried
to reform health care in the u.s. deal
with that problem and probably about
every 17 years on average there was a
big attempt to reform health care and
they always failed and they always
failed because they failed between two
extremes there were two extreme views
that could never quite meet in the
middle ground and they come to what I
talked about last time which is how do
we solve the problem of market failures
and insurance markets well one version
of solving that I described was
subsidization you could remember with my
MIT program if I paid the healthy guys
500 bucks that all by - and I'd solved
the problem
so one version with subsidization the
problem is subsidization only works if
it's big enough to overcome these
problems and no one ever proposed
subsidization big enough to overcome
these problems in my MIT example I was
gonna get four dollars are very healthy
first of all means giving money to
healthy people which is sort of
political a little difficult like hey
the healthier you are the more money you
get seems a bit weird also it's just
hard to solve these problems by just
subsidizing people insurance companies
are still too good at trying to get rid
of the sick people and even if you
subsidized people to come in insurance
covers will always have an incentive
they'll say great healthy will come a
subsidy I still want to avoid the sick
so it doesn't solve the problem the
insurance companies I did talk about
this last time as MIT insurance company
I should try to shed the sick people and
that problem still existed under this
solution the other extreme which is sort
of back in style again is the
single-payer model which is saying look
let's just have the government provide
health insurance to everyone we have the
government price social security
everyone the government's health
insurance to every elderly in America
through Medicare everyone over 65 in
America boom gets government provided
health insurance talk about socialism
okay every American gets that in Canada
every everybody gets sick gets
government provided health insurance why
not just do it here let's get rid of all
the crap with insurance companies we
don't like after all insurance company
administrative costs are about 15% of
medical spending so boom we could lower
Matt 15% of medical spending that is you
know that's like five hundred billion
dollars a year boom it's gone okay so
basically why not so single-payer is
something a lot of people advocated for
let's just have one giant universal
health insurance program now the problem
with this the problem of the
single-payer approach is largely there's
pros and cons economics perspective but
the problems here are largely political
which is that to make single-payer
happen you have three enormous political
barriers which come back to economics
everything comes back to economics but
they play their way out in the political
system okay the first problem is paying
for it
ping
for it which is that single-payer to get
have the government give everyone health
insurance means a massive expansion the
government which means a big increase in
taxes and we know taxes have deadweight
loss and what taxes are politically
unpopular now here's what's misleading
about that here's the fundamental thing
so I worked for the state of Vermont the
state of Vermont want to do their own
single-payer plan if any place can do
its Vermont they're like super Lefty
they essentially have one insurance care
which is Blue Cross anyway they're a
small state it seemed like venez can do
Fremont was gonna do it so I worked with
them to put the numbers together what it
would cost them and I good news and bad
news the good news who I said to Vermont
if you do single-payer you will lower
the cost of health care in Vermont total
by at least 10 percent at least that was
conservative the bad news is to pay for
it you're gonna have to more than double
the entire amount of taxes collected in
the state of Vermont and that second
sentence just could killed everything
okay what's the problem the problem is
that right now health insurance in
America is paid for by by essentially a
hidden tax what's the hidden tax it's
the fact that when your employer gives
you health insurance they pay you less
wages as a result remember a tax
incidence discussion and we said that
essentially tax to the employer
Falls the employer employee depending on
basically elasticity's we can think of
health insurance the same way when
you're poor gives you health insurance
he didn't just eat the whole cost he
says look I'm paying you a total set of
compensation part of which is health
insurance so I'm gonna pass the cost
that health is on at least partially to
your wages that's essentially a hidden
tax so at MIT right now I have a health
service plan through MIT which cost
about eighteen thousand dollars a year
for my family I pay about six thousand a
year on my paycheck MIT pays twelve
thousand but the truth is MIT pays me
twelve thousand less they don't just
give me that health insurance out the
goodness of their heart they take it out
of my wages or at least partially out of
my wages that's essentially a hidden tax
that Americans pay over you to finance
health insurance if we went to
single-payer that hidden tax will go
away I
$12,000 race that's great but it also
face a high new taxation to pay for have
to pay for the government-sponsored plan
now given the total cost would fall we
should be able to net this out in a way
that most people win the problem then
becomes the politics which is your
tracing a hidden tax with a not hidden
tax and that's very ugly politically so
people don't believe their employers
will pay them more if you don't make the
employers fight health insurance like
all the employers will just pocket it
and I could teach some tax incidence -
my face is blue but they just won't
believe it they'll say employers will
just pocket it but I have to pay this
new tax or single-payer so that's the
first problem single payer faces is that
people don't really understand that
trade-off between getting rid of the
hidden tax and adding a new non hidden
tax that's problem one problem two is
the problem we talked a little bit about
behavioral economics and about loss
aversion there's a general feature what
we call status quo bias in human
thinking status quo bias which is
essentially it is harder for me to give
up what I'm used to
then then to grab something new we
talked about the mug example member I
talked about mug so basically you had to
pay anymore to get the mug away from me
that I was willing to pay to buy it then
once you have something you value it
more than if you didn't have it yet
right now six three of Americans have
employer-sponsored insurance and if we
say to them give that up for Bernie care
okay they're gonna be like I don't know
I kind of like my employer sponsor it's
you know yeah you might tell me Bernie
care it's gonna be better but that's
just you talking I know what I have
right now which I'm Clara sponsored
insurance I don't want to move away from
that status quo so status quo bias makes
it hard in general - radical changes on
an economic system and this is a perfect
example to be hard to get people to give
up what they have for something that
they don't really know about yet okay
that's second problem the third problem
is once again about money but really
beyond the scope of this course which is
the problem of the insurance companies
and lobby which is that the insurance
business is big business in America
health insurance companies make about
900 billion dollars a year
okay if you said to them hey health
there's companies you know would you
mind
you guys mind just giving up your 900
billion dollars so we can have
single-payer health care but like I say
yeah it's been a good run go for it no
they're gonna lobby and fight that
because they want to keep their business
and that's gonna be pretty hard for us
to overcome so single-payer has always
struggled with dealing with these kinds
of political problems and that's why
we've been stuck we've been stuck
between one alternative subsidization
the other alternative which is
single-payer okay and that's where
economists have come in came in in the
2000s folks like myself to talk about a
new alternative way to do it okay which
was essentially to try to bring in some
of the best features of these two
approaches okay
and we does the solution we proposed so
I if you want to read more about this
I've actually written a comic book to
explain it it's a graphic novel
technically it's called healthcare
reform it's like 9 bucks on Amazon and
so I like to think of everything in
terms of images now I'm not gonna draw
one doctor I draw anything but the way I
like to think about this is solution we
came up with which we first pioneered
here in Massachusetts and then brought
to the whole country through the
Affordable Care Act is what we call a
three-legged stool approach three-legged
stool approach leg one is deal with this
problem
deal with the insurance discrimination
problem and so leg one is ban insurer
discrimination
no more pre-existing conditions no more
medical underwriting that is if I walk
in the door and you have offered anyone
you have to offer me health insurance at
the average price for my age and you
have to offer to me so any four-year-old
who walks through the door wanting
insurance you have to sell to them if to
sell them at a fixed forty-year-old
price you can't say you're sick I'm not
gonna sell to you okay so the first step
is to ban insurer discrimination to try
to solve that problem
now the problem this raises is you have
simply create if you do this alone
you've created a new problem which is if
you tell insurers they can't
discriminate against the sick you don't
solve the adverse selection problem you
just making sure is gobank
okay now here's the way I like to think
of it I'm sure none of you ever gambled
on sports but if you had gambled on
sports you might know the way sports
gambling works is that there's a guy in
the middle called the bookie and the
bookies goal is to not is to get exactly
the same number of bets on either team
so no man so they take no risk and just
make their profits off the top
so what bookies do is they set point
spreads so the Patriots played the
Dolphins this past weekend I am sadly
I'm a Dolphins fan
okay patron dolphins the point spread
was something like Tenny we know what
the spread was in the Patriots game I
think it's like eight points so they
Dench spread was chosen the patrons of
favorite by E what that meant was your
bet was either the Patriots win by eight
or more or the Dolphins win or the
Patriots win by eight or by less than
eight so one side is page one by eight
or more one side his Patriots win by
less than eight or dolphins win and the
reason you have that biased thing is
because people think the Patriots are
better they are better and as a result
you want to get if you said an even bet
page two and dolphins win everywhere bed
in the Patriots you'd lose money so you
want an equal distribution of risks so
what you want is you want to set the
point spread so the distortion of risk
is equal then having done that you just
make your money off the top now imagine
I passed the law which said all sports
books have to reopen at halftime and
make the same bets available that made
before the game started well those of
you watch the exciting game this weekend
you realize at halftime became pretty
obvious the Patriots weren't gonna win
by eight that is a lot closer game than
people thought so the reopen that a
bunch people would suddenly bet against
the Patriots the pate resented up losing
and the insurers would have gone
bankrupt the bookie would have gone
bankrupt okay insurers are just bookies
that's all they are they just want a
predictable distribution of risks so if
you tell them you have to are for health
is are starting from the same price but
only the sick are gonna buy they're
gonna lose money so that's why we need
the second leg of the stool which I
talked about last time which was the
individual mandate
the individual mandate which is to say
okay insurers if you offer health
adjouris everyone at a fair price we
will as
our part of the deal make sure everyone
buys health insurance so when the 40
year old walks into your office wanting
insurance you can no it's not because
they're sick just because they have to
so we say to insurers you price
insurance fairly and in return we'll
make sure you get the fair to shoes risk
so you say to me in my MIT insurance you
price insurance of 1,500 no try to keep
out the sick I'll make sure everyone
buys so you make your hundred dollar
profit so that's the mandate was
essentially trying to bring was trying
to allow get rid of just discrimination
by bringing in the entire pool of people
so insurance compared lis price the
problem with that is you can't mandate
something people can't afford okay so in
Massachusetts where we're creating is
plan in the mid-2000s a typical family
health insurance policy was about twelve
thousand dollars a year the poverty line
for a family was twenty two thousand
dollars a year we couldn't exactly
mandate people they'd spend fifty five
percent of their income on health
insurance that was not really feasible
so a third leg of the stool we came up
with is subsidies to make health
insurance affordable saying if you're
low income we will offset the cost of
your insurance just like the subsidy
approach here well offset the cost of
your insurance to make it more formal we
do it on the income related basis so it
doesn't cost so much so don't have to
pay for everyone's insurance like single
payer remember single payer is
essentially taking someone like me who's
happy with my insurance swapping it out
for a new government insurance this is
saying no if you're happy with insurance
stick with your insurance but if you're
low income and can't access the employer
market this gives you a new place to go
and that was the idea that became Romney
care the plan here in Massachusetts and
eventually then became Obamacare or the
Affordable Care Act okay so this is
essentially the idea of that plan now
did it work um unambiguously yes now you
won't find anyone more biased than me on
this question but I think what I think
if I've tried to teach you one thing in
this class it's that we need to rely on
real facts wherever possible and if not
we could turn to theory but here we have
a set of real facts that we could turn
to which is that essentially what we did
in Massachusetts with this laws we
covered about two thirds of the
uninsured population at the federal
level we
about 45% of the uninsured population it
was a lower number because the federal
law did not apply to undocumented
immigrants which are about 1/4 of the
uninsured it's not an issue in
Massachusetts a big issue in other
places it's about a quarter of the
uninsurance the federal law did not
apply to undocumented immigrants so as a
result the share cover was lower but a
large number are covered yeah great
question so there are three reasons why
people left uninsured the first reason
was 1/4 of the uninsured undocumented
immigrants and the law didn't apply to
them so right now the upper bound was
75% just to start the second reason is
that the individual mandate contained
exemptions to make it both a little more
humane and quite frankly politically
feasible so if you could not get if your
income was below the poverty line you
were not subject to the individual
mandate and if you could not get
insurance for less than 8 percent of
your income you're not subject to
individual mandate so there are
exemptions and the third thing was the
individual mandate was not like we're
gonna throw you in jail it was a tax
penalty and many people decide they'd
rather just pay the penalty than buy
health insurance so for those three
reasons the number of people did not get
health insurance under the Affordable
Care Act now there's a bunch of
interesting question why should the
mandate penalty a bigger how should we
handle that there's a lot of I could go
for hours on this but that's basically
the structure of what we had okay so
basically that worked it didn't get to
see universal coverage it wasn't as
effective as single-payer would have
been but it was the largest single
insurance expansion American history and
the evidence is clear brought many
people into insurance in improve
people's suits of health care and
improved health so basically that was
kind of the kind of the step forward on
access now the problem with this is it's
only a step there's still many uninsured
and this has been politically really
challenging okay because these two
answers are quite simple just give
people one here's have single-payer this
is super complicated okay I talked about
these in about 15 seconds each this took
five minutes to go through okay and
people thought it was just too
complicated didn't make sense lots of
reason we can talk lots of reasons
people didn't like it so it's never
really been as politically successful as
people like myself who helped develop it
would have hoped and it's left a lot of
people uninsured so we haven't solved
the
probably made a big step forward but we
haven't solved it and that's the ongoing
debate today we see particularly on the
Democratic Party the Republican Party
really doesn't focus much on insurance
coverage but Democratic Party does and
there that's why there there's a lot of
energy behind single-payer right now is
like look you tried the kind of halfway
ground that kind of worked but not
didn't work all the way so let's just go
all the way to single-payer yeah yeah
basically a lot actually it's quite
interesting well it worked quite well
medica a lot of people who are uninsured
actually our people are already eligible
for free Medicaid coverage and just
don't take it now we don't quite know
why it could be language barriers they
don't understand a lot of people a lot a
lot of even legal immigrants just don't
understand they're eligible it could be
people just don't want a government
handout they're embarrassed taking help
from the government could people think I
don't need it I'm never gonna be sick
we don't know why so part of what the
mandate did was say look you already
have free health insurance just pay
attention and take it that's part of the
effect it had was bringing people in so
a large part of the coverage increase is
actually bringing people who are already
eligible just weren't taking it up
before okay
so that's kind of where we are so where
we stand now in coverage is we've taken
a giant step forward we've covered
probably about now probably between a
third and 40% of the uninsured in
America but we're sort of right now kind
of stuck at that point and the question
is do we just sort of stick there or do
we try something more aggressive at with
the political problems I don't know but
that's gonna be the challenge the
challenge going forward okay so that's
questions about that is--that's we're on
problem number one which is accessing
coverage now let's turn to problem
number two which is costs cost is way
harder what I just did was the easy part
it's way hard look at your health care
costs and here's why two facts that are
seemingly contrary to do you think about
it fact one since 1950 US spending on
health care as a share of our economy
has quadrupled we've got
and more than quadruple gone for four
percent of our GDP being health care to
over 17 percent and it's been worth it
if you look at the improvements in our
health and you value them in the way
economists do which is we have valued
statistical values of life we approach
we apply versus provides improvement
health the improvement our health has
been worth the money spent in health
care you guys don't really that health
care totally sucked in nineteen fifty
okay babies born in nineteen fifty were
four times as likely to die before they
reached their first birthday if you had
a heart attack in nineteen fifty you
were four times likely to die within the
first year to put it in terms all young
healthy people care about if you hurt
your knee skiing in nineteen fifty tore
your ACL in nineteen fifty eight or ear
cartilage you're in the hospital for a
week you're on crutches for six weeks
eight hours I use the rest of your life
today you go to an outpatient center you
get author scopic surgery you're back on
the slopes a couple weeks later okay
healthcare is just way better and our
health is way better America is a much
better off nation spending seventeen
percent of GDP on health with how
healthy we are than we were in nineteen
fifty and once again do the economists
test
no one ever advertises hey would you
like nineteen fifties health care
nineteen fifties prices no one out
there's offering that because it's worth
it
that's fact one fact to is we waste a
huge amount of money on health care by
some estimates about a third of what we
spend on health care is totally wasteful
does nothing to improve our health now
how can those two facts to be consistent
it's worth it but it's wasteful well the
answer is that the other two-thirds is
super awesome that basically the
increase in health care works been
productive has been amazing what we've
dragged along all this unproductive
spending - so it's good news and bad
news so the good news is well that's
great
we just cut out the 1/3 that's
unproductive we solved our problem ok
literally if we could just simply cut
out the one-third so productive we spend
the same mad as Europe doesn't health
care we'd solve our entire long-run
fiscal problem the bad news is that it's
easy to look back and see what the
one-third was it's hard to look forward
and say what it's going to be that
health care comes with a huge amount of
uncertainty
about what's going to work and what's
going to be worth it and as a result it
is very hard to say okay fine we'll
cover this we'll cover that because it's
hard to know what's gonna work and
what's not and so essentially you're in
this very difficult spot so what what
are the kind that's a sort of
fundamental trade-off that we face so
what are the potential solutions to this
problem
so essentially um there's a couple of
different solutions to the problem okay
two different paths we can follow okay
path one is the regulatory path which is
basically path that Europe follows what
Europe does is they just much much more
heavily regulate the delivery of health
care and they do that in two ways one is
the extra of regulations in some case
about what healthcare you can get so for
instance England has the euphemistically
name nice the nationalists you forever
effectiveness which actually tells
people they can't get some things
it literally rations so for example for
many years it's no longer true in
England if you're over 75 you could not
get a transplant said look we've got a
limited number of kidneys you're gonna
die soon anyway let's give the kidney to
a young person actually kind of makes
sense okay the idea is look we have a
some donor kidneys why should it be
earned by some random factor like when
you got online you should be turned by
who gets the most value from the kidney
it's gonna be someone who's 30 not so
known as 75 okay so one regular route is
to literally have regulations like that
that's actually pretty rare most
countries don't actually regulate in
that way most countries kind of let you
get what your doctor says you should get
there's three routes so one route is
sort of regulatory the other route of
regulate so one route is sort of what we
call sort of regulating you know I don't
call it access sort of technological
regulation regularly which technology
you can get the second kind of
regulation Europe is supply regulation
so they basically don't let there be
many doctors and
um they're not many doctors in hospitals
so there are as many MRI machines in LA
as there are in Canada okay basically
just not many place to go get an MRI in
Canada so if you hurt your knee
in the u.s. you go you get an MRI like
the next day in Canada you get it six
weeks later okay so only way to control
is to actually regulate the supply of
medical care just give people less stuff
they can use and the third way to
control the third regulatory mechanism
and the most important is price
regulation we are the only nation in the
world which essentially lets the free
market determine the price of healthcare
services every other nation regulates
the prices that people pay for their
health care services now the question we
have to ask is why why does that make
sense well the answer would be that we
think it would make sense if we think
there's a fundamental market failure in
the determination of healthcare prices
and in fact it turns out there are
numbers of market failures and
termination of health care prices so one
market failure for example is imperfect
information I don't know I can't shop
effectively when I'm in the back of the
ambulance dying from heart attack can't
be like you know that house but it looks
expensive take me over there I want to
shop there you can't really shop it's a
hard it's harder to shop and if you
couldn't prices aren't posted you don't
really know what it costs you your heart
attack treated in different places
there's imperfect information there's
also imperfect competition which is if
you have your heart attack on Cape Cod
there's like one huh huh kit which is an
island with no way off but a ferry
there's like one place to go there's one
hospital they have perfect monopoly okay
you just you can't get off the island
you're gonna die otherwise so it's
imperfect competition
there's even imperfect competition where
you think the competition might be
perfect so take Boston there are so many
hospitals in Boston you cannot literally
fall down without hitting a hospital
okay yet there is an enormous dispersion
the prices hospitals charge in
particular the very famous hospitals
like Mass General Hospital charge
multiples of what less famous hospitals
charge even though let's also like
really nearby
I will because they have essentially we
call a reputational monopoly then even
though they don't actually physical
monopoly people like I want to go to
that G H they're the best even if
they're not going so the best they just
have this view of being the best and
they could charge higher price as a
result even if their outcomes are
necessarily better in other markets we
think perfect information would allow us
to get rid of these kinds of
inefficiencies it doesn't exist in
health care as a result perfect
competition still does not work in
health care price setting and as a
result all other countries regular
health care price in big not other
countries even the US or regular health
care prices so the Medicare program has
regulated prices that covers millions of
Americans it's just for the
non-government broad health insurance in
the US there's non regulated prices okay
now I am NOT despite my tone saying that
regulating prices is the answer it's not
clear raylene prices comes with a huge
number of additional problems like we
talked about we talked about regulating
monopolies which is the government may
not know the proper price to set the
government do a terrible job that may
get lobbied they may be corrupt
indeed in the u.s. in the 1970s
virtually every state did regulate
hospital prices and every state went
away from that because they thought the
system was broken so it's not like
there's any dismount the European
solution is an easy answer that's why
the other route to people in pushing
lately is a different route which is the
incentives route which is basically to
say look we don't want a regular
supplier prices what we're going to do
is we're going to say doctors and
hospitals you get together and form
these units we call accountable care
organizations a cos this is a big
innovation of the Affordable Care Act of
Obamacare set up these a cos these are
hospitals and doctors all get together
it'd be basically like soup to nuts all
the health care you need in one group
and we say to them we are gonna pay you
one flat amount of money to care for
John and then within that you decide
what he gets you decide what prices
everybody pays and makes you figure all
that out but we're gonna be flat them
out in particular that flat amount is
not gonna rise much and that's why we
bring the cost of healthcare under
control we're gonna baste
every ACO will get an amount let's we'll
get the math it's a flat amount and she
won't rise much okay and that's how
bring health care costs under control
that has a number of wonderful features
first of all it's much less evil
sounding than things like not only of
MRIs are regulating what prices okay
second of all this much fewer regulatory
tools we just say here's a flat amount
were giving you per person and we're
done okay so that sounds great the
problem is we haven't been able to get
it to work and that's because it turns
out doctor nozzles aren't very good at
figuring how to set price and set supply
they're just not they don't how to
really figure this out and the ACO so
far I've not actually performed very
well they've not saved much money so
really we're stuck between a route which
seems a lot easier but we haven't really
figured how to make work and a route
which has worked all around the world
but sees politically nightmarish and
that's kind of where we are right now in
terms of controlling costs and that's
difficult spot we find ourselves in but
then be clear this is not like oh that's
sort of interesting John I'll go home
and forget about it now this is the
entire future okay
healthcare costs are the key to term in
the entire fiscal future of the US as I
mentioned last lecture the US is
currently SN about seventy five trillion
dollars in deficit over the long run
seventy trillion of that is healthcare
okay health care is the single
determinant of the u.s. fiscal balance
in the long run
literally it's the single most important
government problem facing health care
also signals a foreign government
problem facing your generation next
generations I like to say that all that
matters we think about the future is
health care costs and global warming
because either way we're underwater
okay basically those are the two big
issues we have to face going forward so
this is a serious issue that you're
generations you have to struggle with
sorry as you as you go on
so that's health care in the u.s. in 40
minutes so this class you know there's a
famous skit from Saturday Night Live
which is what you remember five years
after college it's and it's five minutes
and three and a half minutes of spring
break okay I don't expect you to
remember the formula for you know if
you're not going on in economics don't
expected
remember the formula for you know
deriving a cost function okay what I
expect you get out of this class is a
and interesting economics and I hope
you'll go on I sincerely hope that and
I'm available to anyone who wants to
talk about the pros and cons of going on
in economics obviously I'm more Pro but
I'm happy to talk about it okay some of
its always feel free to reach out about
that but B even if you don't want any
comics I want this to make you more
educated consumer of the newspaper okay
this is we are in an era as I said in my
very first lecture where truth and facts
and the scientific method are themselves
under attack and MIT is the last bastion
of fighting this war we are the place
that explains a scientific method that
used a scientific method and we need to
use the methods you've learned here to
think intelligently whatever your
conclusions but to think intelligently
about these economics topics and
fundamentally that means being annoying
and to illustrate that I like down with
the joke which some of you may have
heard sorry I apologize if you have so
the joke is a doctor a doctor a priest
and an economist go golfing they get in
the golf course and they hit the golf
course and they're behind someone going
incredibly slowly I don't know if many
golfers among you but the idea is if
you're very slow figure out you're
supposed to allow the people behind you
to play through and get ahead of you
this person won't let anyone play
through and he's like fifty shots a hole
it's disgusting
okay and there's like 50 people lined up
behind this guy and these folks are so
disgusted they quit after nine holes
they go back to the clubhouse they're
pounding their beers like what an
[ __ ] I can't believe you wouldn't let
us play through it ruin our day and so
it goes up to them and says excuse me
are you new to this club and they said
yes we are said well I could tell you're
new to the club because if you weren't
new you have known the person I'm
playing behind is blind and actually
it's a miracle you can get the ball in
the hole at all and it usually gets it
an honor to be the same course as he is
and the person walks away and there's
like a deadly silence and that people at
the table like wow I feel terrible and
and the doctor goes I can't I feel
terrible I can't believe him myself a
man of healing would be so insulting
towards someone who's blind I'm gonna
dedicate a wing of my hospitals of the
blind and turns the priest the priest
says I can't believe myself a man of the
cloth and I ain't supposed to care for
the UH the less able
Society would do this I'm gonna set up a
free soup kitchen for the blind and they
turn to the economist economists as well
if he's blind why doesn't just play at
night and makes sense right and
basically the point is that the job of
the economist is to sort of be annoying
and look for the basic flaws and
arguments to understand them to ask the
difficult questions but to have
responsible answers and that's what I
hope you'll get out of this course I
hope you'll take forward with you so
thank you very much sharing it with me
and good luck on the final
[Applause]